if it's getting a bit colder in your
part of the world this month you can
always cozy up indoors with some video
games if you're an Xbox Live Gold member
and want to know what you can play for
free in October I've got you covered and
good news for all you scaredy cats out
there none of these games are Halloween
themed first up for Xbox one is gone
home the debut game from indie studio
fulbright it's a simple story girl comes
home from a trip abroad to find her
family home totally empty where'd
everybody go
you can explore the house and learn all
about your missing parents and sister
with a couple twists along the way gone
home will be available all month long
Xbox one players can also get their
hands on the Turing test if you're not
familiar with the concept that's the
test that determines whether a machine
can appear totally indistinguishable
from a human so combine that idea with a
mysterious Space Station and you've got
all the ingredients for a
philosophically deep puzzle game the
Turing test will be available October
16th through November 15 moving to the
previous generation Xbox 360 players can
try out rayman 3 HD originally released
as Rayman 3 hoodlum havoc this is where
the series took its more humorous turn
it's still a beloved platformer but a
few laughs along the way only helped
prettier graphics and better performance
ain't too bad either Rayman 3 HD will be
available October 1st through the 15th
finally the 360 is also getting medal of
honor airborne
this definitely isn't where the series
got funny but this entry did change
things up by dropping you from a c-47 at
the beginning of every match letting you
choose a more tactical landing spot on
the battlefield medal of honor airborne
will be available October 16th through
the 31st and thanks to backwards
compatibility both this and Rayman can
also be played on Xbox one and those are
your free games with gold for October
2017 remember that you can always check
out gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles over at GameSpot and if you want
to keep up with all of our top stories
you can grab the official game spot now
app on iOS and Android
[Music]